bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 17 février
enseignants et parents d'élèves ne
veulent pas de la carte scolaire
proposée par le ministre pour la rentrée
de neil ceylan gard et l'hérault que la
mobilisation est la plus forte des
propositions pour une meilleure gestion
des libérations conditionnelles des
détenus condamnés reportage près
d'evreux en compagnie d'un juge
d'application des peines élections
législatives très importante demain en
iran les réformistes attend de nouveaux
soutiens mais la crise économique
accroît le nombre de laissés pour compte
de la révolution iranienne
quarante huit heures avant le match de
rugby france angleterre pour le tournoi
des six nations nous évoquerons la
nature particulière des relations entre
les deux nations autour du ballon ovale
cinéma avec la carte du monde le film de
scott elliott histoire d'une femme dont
la vie bascule d'un coup entre
dépression et demeure si leurs rêves et
leur interprète cette femme elle nous
fait l'honneur d'être ce soir notre
invité
on a beau dire que février est un mois
traditionnellement agitée dans le monde
scolaire puisque c'est la période où
s'élabore la carte pour la rentrée
suivante dans le primaire il n'empêche
que les manifestations les grèves et les
occupations d'écoles se succèdent depuis
plusieurs semaines le ministre claude
allègre part de rumeurs de supputations
et même de fantasmes en contestant les
chiffres fournis dans les syndicats
d'enseignants sur le manque de personnel
les parents d'élèves ont rejoint les
professeurs dans les départements du
gard et de l'hérault et réclament
maintenant plus de 1100 postes nouveaux
en rapport avec une augmentation
démographique
voyez le reportage de véronique et
gleason et pascal pons
pour le gard symboliquement parents et
enseignants ont situé leur action
d'aujourd'hui sur un péage entre le gard
et l'hérault
les deux départements partagent la même
colère et la même pénurie
le gars comme les rôles sont touchés par
l'absence d'emploi une insuffisance
d'emploi et aussi par une démographie en
croissance en 10 ans alors que la
population scolaire françaises diminuées
de 160 mille élèves ici en
languedoc-roussillon 1 en accueillez
trente mille de plus les classes devenus
souvent surchargés parfois dans un
univers des misères sociales ont mimé
ricol soit qu'avait mais kia en matière
de performances scolaires un peu
dégringolé des gens des premières places
que la veille à 25 ans aux toutes
dernières toute la ville de lunel est
classé zone d'éducation prioritaire
la population du canton a augmenté de
près de 30% en dix ans la scolarisation
est souvent un facteur d'intégration
mais les enseignants sont obligés de
refuser l'inscription des moins de 3 ans
donner envie aux enfants d'apprendre
j'appris pour le cp il faut qu'ils
sachent ce que ça veut dire lire écrire
que l'aventuré du sens et sans peut pas
le faire quand il ya trente enfants
autour qui monte au rideau comme à lunel
des dizaines d'écoles de l'hérault et du
gard sont mobilisés depuis deux à trois
semaines réclamant 1130 poste dès le
début les parents et parfois les élus
ont soutenu le mouvement
il ya des parents d'élèves qui sont
allés dans le terreau prennent aux
écoles et qui disent ça n'a pas bougé
depuis que nous on ya été enfant voilà
alors que je veux dire la population de
lunel a vraiment c'est vraiment une
explosion démographique et rien ne bouge
c'est vrai que la municipalité suit
jusqu'à qu'un stade mais après les
épaves plus suivre tokyo en est tenaillé
entre le ministère et et la commune qui
n'a pas qu'il n'y a pas les moyens de
pouvoir à la fois construire des écoles
à la fois rénové les anciennes écoles vu
le manque de le manque de budget
il ne suffit donc pas de rêver que le
ministère lâche de nouveaux postes pour
certaines communes défavorisées
il faudra en plus les moyens financiers
de construire de nouvelles classes il y
avait erreur il faut le reconnaître la
vache malade du morbihan n'était pas une
vache folle la suspicion qui portait sur
l'abattoir galets du sourn dans le
morbihan a entraîné un préjudice
considérable selon son pdg qui déplorait
que dans cette affaire suspicion et valu
condamnation les résultats des examens
pratiqués sur la bête par le laboratoire
de pathologie de lyon sont en effet
négatif mais ces résultats arrive bien
tard non seulement pour les abattoirs
mais aussi pour l'éleveur c'est aussi
une mise en accusation de la direction
des services vétérinaires qui serait
aller un peu vite en besogne
reportage à plouvain c'est au nord de
brest avec jacques devaux à gabriel
camilla et les commentaires de ce film
et elle les résultats viennent de tomber
ils sont sans appel il ne s'agit pas
d'un nouveau cas de vache folle tout est
parti dissident cet abattoir installé
près de pontivy
mercredi dernier une vache un peu trop
maigre et boitant légèrement est
découvert par les services vétérinaires
du morbihan est elle malade elle ne
possède en tout cas pas de certificat
vétérinaire d'information la bête est
aussitôt isolé a battu on pense alors à
un nouveau cas de vache folle pour lui
rossignol pdg de l'abattoir que nous
avons joint ce soir par téléphone
suspicion a valu condamnation
l'entreprise gallet a toujours effectué
sur l'activité avec le même
professionnalisme et respect des
procédures de contrôle à tous les stades
de la production dans l'entreprise
depuis l'arrivée des animaux jusqu'à
l'expédition
les services vétérinaires sont ils allés
trop vite au nom du principe de
précaution chez l'éleveur installé à
plouvien non loin de brest
on regrette ces jugements hâtifs qui
portent dit-il préjudice à toute la
profession
on peut prétendre qu'une administration
une déséquipés tué son blond j'aurais
pas dû qu'à un certain stade qui a mis
la vache en consigne est parti balancer
dans la presse des choses qu'il ne
fallait pas faire
on a demandé le principe de précaution
il existe un qui fonctionne dans les
deux sens on soupçonnait l'agriculture
d'avoir voulu se débarrasser
discrètement une vache malade
la bête selon lui n'avait que le nerf
sciatique coincé pas de quoi nécessité
un certificat vétérinaire une extrême
prudence doit pourtant être de règle
la france enregistré six nouveaux cas
d'encéphalopathie spongiforme bovine
depuis le début de l'année un programme
de dépistage systématique sur un
échantillon de 40000 bovins va être
lancée d'ici un mois
il permettra notamment de mieux cerner
la mallette en matière de justice les
remises en liberté conditionnelle sont
trop rares trop sélective et leur
gestion administrative est à revoir
c'est un dans un rapport un rapport
remis par daniel farge conseiller à la
cour de cassation ne voit ici en
compagnie de m libre ont ce rapport il
ya 23 propositions parmi lesquelles la
possibilité pour les détenus de faire
appel pour les décisions de refus et
l'assouplissement des critères d'octroi
de cette liberté conditionnelle et puis
il conviendra de renforcer les
compétences des juges d'application des
peines les [ __ ]
valérie ermite et nathalie gallet ont
accompagné une juge d'application des
peines dans un centre de détention près
d'evreux c'est le plus grand d'europe où
les condamnés partage des illusions et
des espérances devant la quasi
inexistence des libérations
conditionnelles
marie-christine tour c'est un [ __ ]
un juge d'application des peines un
magistrat peu connu du grand public mais
un juge essentiel en prison sa mission
est de veiller à l'exécution des
condamnations décidé par d'autres juges
mais c'est surtout lui qui décide des
réductions et des aménagements de peine
un pouvoir sans appel car les détenus en
tout cas un moyen de contester ces
décisions du courrier est arrivé pour
quatre jours à progrès qui correspondent
à des différentes demandes de détenus
pour des aménagements diverses de peine
dans ces fichiers près de 800 détenus
condamnés à cinq ans ou 15 ans voire à
perpétuité pour 24 d'entre eux leur
éventuelle libération conditionnelle est
entre les mains du juge ou du garde des
sceaux
s'ils sont qu'on aime y a plus de cinq
ans de prison depuis 30 ans le nombre de
ces libérations est en chute libre
en 73 30 % des détenus qui pouvaient en
bénéficier l'avait obtenu ils n'étaient
que 14 % en 98 riehl auzits et/ou peur
de la récidive
ce détenu pourrait y prétendre mais ils
n'y pensent même sur le temps division
de la division des longues peines les
libérations conditionnelles sont ici un
sujet qui fâche et qui désespère à la
fois les condamnés à 20 ans de prison il
côtoie les perpète et leur discours est
identique
j'ai de poser trop fort trop projet de
coter ce notre roger ce qui s'est passé
exactement
c'est la désespérance complètement
l'estomac l'aise avec les gens roulent
moins et au suicide mais paya plus long
et chaud et note d'espoir la libération
conditionnelle peut être attribuée à
mi-peine ou après 15 ans de détention
pour les perpétuité il faut pour
l'obtenir n'être plus considérés comme
dangereux bien sûr et présenter des
gages sérieux de réinsertion sociale
en clair disposer d'un revenu une fois
dehors ils inquiets nous réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité par exemple on
vous demande un certificat travail le
chili
le contexte socio économique ne se prête
pas l' embauche je ne parle
deuxièmement vous n'avez pas de date de
sortie ça c'est de l'hypocrisie pure et
simple
comment demander un chef d'entreprise de
vous faire un certificat travail alors
qu'il fait patrons veulent sortir
pourtant tout le monde est d'accord la
libération conditionnelle est un bon
moyen de réinsertion et de contrôle
car au moindre faux pas le détenu peut
retourner en prison
l'intérêt c'est qu'il ya suivi c'était
la personne est épaulé c'est qu'on peut
recadrer les choses c'est qu'on peut en
discuter c'est qu'on peut le le préparer
à la ville doit l'aider à retrouver une
vie normale après des années passées en
prison alors que lorsqu'il n'ya pas
libération conditionnelle la personne 10
ans 15 ans prison et fort le directeur
de la prison partage le même avis que le
juge d'application des peines car les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes il y a près
de deux fois moins de récidive parmi les
détenus ayant bénéficié d'une libération
conditionnelle
la haute cour de justice de londres
ayant décidé de communiquer le rapport
médical sur l'état de santé d'abou busto
pinochet ou justice des pays qui en
ferait la demande
la fuite du document n'a pas tardé les
premiers à le publier sur les journaux
espagnols d hier et les protestations
contre ce manquement secret ne
changeront rien le tout est de savoir
maintenant si des contre expertises sont
possibles dès comment interpréter 2010
atteignant ce fameux document médical
qui devaient rester confidentielles oui
six heures d'entretiens le 15 janvier
dernier et un rapport de 13 pages
suffisent pour sceller le sort
judiciaire de pinochet les trois
médecins britanniques disent ainsi
s'être trouvés face à un homme presque
sourd présentant des signes
parkinsoniens et souffrant d'une lésion
au cerveau
à aucun moment les experts qualifient le
dictateur de sénile il parle simplement
de détérioration importante des
fonctions intellectuelles autrement dit
augusto pinochet est en mesure
d'assister à son procès en fauteuil
roulant mais avec le risque de ne rien
comprendre débat alors je vais vous dire
maintenant les procédures qu'est ce qui
ferait des l'image d'un avion en bout de
piste prêt à ramener pinochio pays
semble lointaine elles datent pourtant
seulement de 15 jours
aujourd'hui plus secret médical plus de
stricte confidentialité préconisée par
les magistrats britannique
la france l'espagne la belgique la
suisse désormais détentrice du dossier
médical vont devoir se déterminer sous
le regard de pignons public informé dans
tout procès une contre-expertise succède
à une expertise cette contre-expertise
le juge chargé du dossier en france est
en droit de la demande et cette
procédure suivra une voie administrative
via le ministère la justice et le quai
d'orsay de source judiciaire la question
deviendra donc alors diplomatique
pendant ce temps l'état de santé de
pinochet se dégradent les experts
signale au passage que le malade ne
reconnaît pas toujours les siens il
suffirait peut-être de pas grand chose
pour que pinochet oublie son passé de
dictateur merci le mini sur la situation
en tchétchénie le président de
démocratie libéral alain madelin demande
à jacques chirac de saisir la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et
d'obtenir la condamnation de la russie
au conseil de l'europe ce matin sur
france 2 daniel cohn bendit était
beaucoup plus radicale il traitait
vladimir poutine président russe par
intérim d'assassins à moscou on réfute
les témoignages sur les tortures et les
camps il n'empêche que lesdits
témoignages sont assez régulièrement
concordants commentaires gilles rabin
avec didier da tous ceux qui sont
enfermés ici ont été arrêtés au hasard
sur une route de tchétchénie l'armée
russe appelle ce genre d'endroit un
point de contrôle
officiellement ne sont contrôlés que les
hommes en âge de porter une arme
les il ya aussi des enfants toute cette
chaîne depuis dix ans est suspect et des
fans comme le montrent ces images ce que
cherche cet officier ce sont les bleus
caractéristiques que les semis fusil sur
l'épaule d'un combattant et personne ne
se préoccupe des serveurs sous ses
sommets moore
car ces points de contrôle sont en
réalité l'antichambre des camps dits de
fixation hier le russe quand on dit et
maintenant nous découvrons qu'ils sont 1
en europe dans un camp de filtration
il a été arrêté le 16 janvier dernier
est interné dans un camp de filtration
témoignage d'un rescapé des muses à nyon
les tympans crevés entendre des doigts
cassés les dents limées la bouche des
chiens dans méthode essentiel d'obtenir
des aides de la brutalité et la torture
la deuxième chaîne de télévision russe a
diffusé hier soir pour la première fois
un reportage sur le camp des filtrations
de charm au kosovo un sujet de commandes
censé démontrer qu'il s'agit d'une
simple et banale prise en charge est en
réalité de répondre aux accusations de
la presse occidentale accusations dans
la plupart des russes n'ont jamais
entendu parler
sous la pression le kremlin a nommé
aujourd'hui un représentant pour les
droits de l'homme en tchétchénie
je suis un fonctionnaire de l'état pour
faire la lumière sur les camps au kosovo
aujourd'hui c'était les serbes qui
accusait les albanais de provocations
entre les violences de mitrovic à la
nuit dernière a été relativement calme
et aujourd'hui à christina plus d'un
millier on parle de plusieurs milliers
d'étudiants à blonay ont manifesté dans
les rues nitrites chat
rappelant que la tension est très vive
entre les différentes communautés ou des
images qui ont détourné difficilement
par les envoyés spéciaux présents dans
cette ville du kosovo nos envoyés
spéciaux en poussines est jugé qu'ils
ont pu suivre la police internationale
composée notamment de canadiens de
zambiens d'irlandais à vrai dire à
suivre le reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux ils paraissent très perdu dans
un climat de tension très difficile
les régions déchiré par des tensions
communautaires thomass brown connaît
bien il est policier en irlande du nord
mais au kosovo il n'y a pas que des
problèmes interethniques et comme tous
les policiers du monde thomas brown
procèdent à des contrôles de routine à
pristina il est accompagné d'un policier
kosovar nouvellement formé cette voiture
à des plaques allemandes mais les
propriétaires n'ont pas les originaux
despatie souvent les propriétaires de
véhicules volés nous présente les
photocopies des papiers on ne peut pas
faire confiance au régime
quelques minutes plus tard dans l'un des
quatre commissariats de pristina bureau
des plaintes à la bbc le policier les
environs
il essaye de comprendre dit à une
traductrice une autre histoire de
véhicules volés 2 à beauvais mais est ce
qu'ils savent qui est le voleur et
quelles sont exactement les
circonstances du vol dans la cour du
même commissariat cette fois c'est un
policier canadien qui réceptionne une
importante pièce à conviction voiture
hier les tabler sur un logiciel de ged
individus ont été trouvés sans vie
quatre véhicules ont ajouté à tous à la
circulation à organiser et une
manifestation de soutien aux albanais de
mitrovica a encadré
et tous les policiers sont sur le
terrain résultat lorsque le central
annonce une urgence la police de l'onu
une première fois qu'on doit se replier
avec demandé à la kfor de nous donner un
coup de main de répondre à l'appel
parce que nous tous nos effectifs sont
ici pour cette manifestation
à peine la moitié des 4800 policiers
internationaux promis à la mission
kouchner sont effectivement présents au
kosovo
la tâche est pourtant immense dans cette
province où circulent trois cent mille
véhicules sans plaque et où beaucoup de
citoyens sont sans patrie la faiblesse
des systèmes policiers pourraient
encourager le grand banditisme à faire
du kosovo la plaque tournante de tous
les trafics ceux qui on a forcément des
répercussions sur le taux de criminalité
pour l'europe entière
l'apparition de slobodan milosevic à
belgrade aujourd'hui devant le congrès
de son parti socialiste celui de serbie
qu'il a fondée et qu'il dirige depuis
dix ans cinq mille personnes tout et
tisanes des évictions taper vite en
discours exaltant la lutte pour
l'indépendance
demain près de 39 millions d'iraniens
sont appelés aux urnes pour élire un
nouveau parlement ce que l'on appelle
les réformateurs espèrent en sortir
renforcés avec à leur tête le président
mohammad khatami
mais la crise économique et sociale est
très forte en iran et l'on est bien loin
des premiers idéaux de la révolution
dans des villages éloignés de téhéran
c'est ce que nous rapportent nos envoyés
spéciaux jean-marc il use et jean
françois renaud le village de bois
ramada bad
ce n'est pas tout à fait la campagne en
bordure de zone industrielle à deux
heures de route de téhéran
c'est un village d'exclus 1500 familles
venues des quatre coins de l'iran vendre
leur courage au travail devant la
mosquée en construction
le cordonnier ambulant rafistole des
chaussures sans âge
ici les promesses de la révolution ne
font plus rêver
on l'attend toujours l'école de filles
les parents sont inquiets quand elle
rentre seul du village voisin
les boues à ciel ouvert irrespirable
quand vient l'été
ça fait dix ans qu'on doit le recouvrir
on leur a demandé 100 fois se plaint
hors caméra le chef de la milice
religieuse
mohammad l'un des cinq membres du
conseil de sages du village ne veux pas
être trop pessimiste
j'ai écrit à l'administration voilà un
an
on ne m'a pas répondu mais on a parlé de
l'égout dans le journal alors soit ils
n'ont pas d'argent
soyez nous négligent on va quand même
aller voter en espérant que les
candidats tiendront leurs promesses
des affiches électorales du candidat
conservateur collé sur un pylône pour
souligner que malgré tout l'électricité
est venu le gaz devrait subir bientôt
mais voilà avec une inflation de plus de
35%
le prix de la viande a triplé en un an
et les chômeurs n'achète plus de
nouvelles chaussettes
un coup dur pour l'atelier de russel un
père de cinq enfants
avec ces trois machines qui tombe sans
cesse en panne
il n'y croit plus recèle son fils
mohammad a quitté l'école à 15 ans pour
l'aider pour l'aider à gagner juste de
quoi ne rien devoir aux autres alors les
élections quand j'avais on a voté tous
les ans on l'espère chaque fois du
nouveau depuis douze ans que je suis ici
rien n'a changé le marchand de
chaussettes de mohammad aouad ne pourra
pas comme l'exigé la tradition
acheter les meubles de sa fille qui va
se marier cette année abu ahmad a bold
on n'a pas vu recettes sourire depuis
longtemps
même si bénie par le pétrole l'islam
révolutionnaire a laissé au bord de la
route des millions de ses fils les
déshérités de l'iran d'aujourd'hui sont
beaucoup plus instruit un iran qui ne
croient plus au miracle mais qui espère
simplement que cette fois ci chaque vote
sera synonyme de changement en roumanie
lé déplacement de la commissaire
européenne à l'environnement margot
wallstrom n'est pas passée inaperçue
elle est venue sur place se rendre
compte des conséquences de la pollution
au cyanure du danube
la compagnie australienne propriétaire
de la mine roumaine à l'origine cette
pollution est mis en cause et madame
valls rome veut appliquer le principe
pollueur payeur
reportage en roumanie nous envoyés
spéciaux les vergnes et andrei sera sa
visite était annoncée et attendue depuis
plusieurs jours
margot wallstroem premier représentant
de l'union européenne à se rendre en
roumanie depuis la catastrophe a été
aujourd'hui l'objet de toutes les
attentions
constatant l'étendue des dégâts et la
vive inquiétude de la population
elle a réaffirmé la volonté européenne
d'aider les pays touchés par le sinistre
nous fournirons toute l'aide possible
nous ferons venir des experts il faut
éviter à l'avenir que pareil accident ne
se reproduise
mais cette visite très encadrée a pris
soudain un tour inattendu vie que le
soulier par le cyanure a touché son vie
à deux kilomètres du site habbo zinta
marais ils sont une quarantaine de
familles à ne plus pouvoir consommer
l'eau de leurs plus il aura fallu quinze
jours à la direction régionale sanitaire
pour les prévenir et leur fournir les
résultats des analyses
on a d'abord dû boire chez les voisins
et puis de l'eau minérale
que voulez vous qu'on fasse comment ne
pas comprendre l'inquiétude de ces
villageois alors même que les
responsables roumains donnent des
versions différentes
aujourd'hui le directeur de la régie des
eaux à incriminer l'hypochlorite de
sodium
cette solution déversés par l'état dans
les rivières afin de neutraliser le
cyanure
visiblement dépassé par l'ampleur de la
catastrophe la roumanie n'a jamais
semblé aussi démunis en 1995 le
gouvernement roumain a adopté une loi
conforme aux normes européennes selon le
principe pollueur payeur mais à ce jour
cette loi n'a jamais été appliquée aux
yeux de l'union européenne il se
pourrait que l'accident de baia mare et
face aujourd'hui figure de test
l'interrogation politiques sur la
gestion économique et social de lionel
jospin qui apparaît en plein changement
sur l'épargné salariale le projet
repoussé sur les retraites les
orientations du gouvernement s'ils ont
retardé à la fin du mois de mars et ses
modifications dans le rythme de l'action
gouvernementale surviennent après des
épisodes plutôt pittoresque de la
cagnotte
alors y at il des choses à en déduire
gérard leclerc en tout cas tout ça ça
donne un peu un sentiment de gaspillage
et d'être fermement et du coup jean
louis debré peut dénoncer l'immobilisme
du gouvernement au moment où les
sondages enregistrent disons un petit
coup de mou alors matignon se défend de
toute peur d'agir le dossier de retraite
aurait été retardée simplement pour des
questions d'agenda du premier ministre
est surbooké mais des décisions
concrètes seraient bien prise et
annoncée à la fin mars
en revanche on admet que l'épargné
salariale est un sujet hautement
sensible et politiquement il n'est pas
abordée lionel jospin en scène en est
pas un chaud partisan et nombreux sont
ceux chez les communistes mais aussi les
socialistes les verts les syndicats qui
frémissent quand on parle d'actionnariat
de participations ou d'épargne-retraite
aussi le gouvernement s'accorde-t-il
deux ou trois mois de concertation pour
trouver des terrains d'entente il ne
ferait donc appliquer la fameuse méthode
jospin la concertation avant les
décisions et puis les dossiers traités
les uns après les autres pour éviter les
télescopages ce qui donnerait bien
disons donc la retraite en mars les
impôts en mai et l'épargné salariale au
mois de juin lors de la 12 et d'une
volonté de réforme n'y a qu'un pas il ya
un pas effectivement disons que jusqu'à
maintenant le gouvernement un peu joué
sur du velours avec des réformes qui
étaient soit clairement estampillés de
gauche comme les 35 heures ou bien qui
lui permettait d'incarner la modernité
comme le pacs ou la parité or maintenant
ils affrontent des des sujets beaucoup
plus ardue comme les retraites on sait
que les mesures ne seront pas agréable
ou bien des terrains qui ne sont pas
traditionnellement les siens
la baisse des impôts c'est l' épargne
retraite qui peuvent provoquer des
raidissement idéologique les
conservatismes de gauche alors que la
majorité des français
les réclames alors le risque est connu
c'est l'immobilisme
un immobilisme grandissant la proche des
élections michel rocard et edouard
balladur en avaient été les victimes on
avait parlé à l'époque d'organisation de
balladurisation le gouvernement jospin
est donc prévenu merci me convient mais
préfet en 200 ans aujourd'hui le
président chirac c'est laid ses
serviteurs de l'état dont les feuilles
de chêne bicentenaire ont été plutôt
secoué lors de la réforme de gaston
defferre en 82 réforme de
décentralisation
le président en a profité pour évoquer
la sécurité première attente des
français en souhaitant que l'on ne
laisse pas s'installer une culture de
l'incivilité
de plus le chef de l'état promet des
économies d'effectifs et de moyens dans
la fonction publique alors il faut
savoir il ya 230 préfet est tellement en
france mais tous ne sont pas de la même
manière il y a les classiques en poste
ils sont 115
d'autres travaillent dans
l'administration publique d'autres
encore sont hors cadre ou bien en
attente d'affectation quelques fois
utilisé pour des missions ponctuelles
olivier caroff yasmina farber avec
thierry breton ont donc choisi de
croiser deux portraits de prêt fait
différent joël de béchu qui hors cadre
occupé par l'indemnisation des tempêtes
à paris et puis bernard fragneau
installé à lons le saunier préfet du
jura préfet ses premiers émois métier
c'est deuxièmement un état d'esprit et
ses 3e - un mode de vie dans le jura
l'état c'est lui bernard fragneau et
préfet depuis un an et demi une vie
publique rythmée par les cérémonies
officielles une vie quotidienne
réglementé jusque dans ses appartements
privés
c'est la loi un préfet habite dans sa
préfecture
c'est une entrée en lice à l'ombre oui
là on est chez moi enfin on est à la
limite entre chez moi qui est derrière
cette porte et que je préserve
jalousement
et puis ce set est là où il y a les
chambres de réception joël le béchec est
revenu à la case ministère de
l'intérieur de ces postes dans les
préfectures du vaucluse et du morbihan
il a gardé deux fidèles collaborateurs
des frères informaticien à vannes une
grève du personnel a mis un terme à son
emploi de préfet territoriale en jargon
administratif c'est un préfet hors cadre
dans un bureau sans charme
moi je demande j'ai un ordinateur je me
sens très bien
le bureau oui la fois les dimensions
d'un placard ou alors c'est considérable
mais c'est vrai qu'il est pas doré
servir l'état métier à risques
bernard fragneau le sait surtout
lorsqu'il faut mettre en place les
mesures décidées en haut lieu ce jour là
il doit convaincre les élus locaux
d'attendre patiemment l'argent promis
par lionel jospin il ya un mois pour les
communes victimes de la tempête
c'est l'homme des écrits ses lobes du
possible
face à lui 250 maires inquiets mais
calme et un fonctionnaire qui évoque le
manque de moyens prévus par l'état
le jour le ministre de l'économie et des
finances sera pas besoin de vos conseils
sur l'ampleur du budget de l'état il
sera plus faire savoir
joel le béchu et une autre mission nommé
monsieur tempête il doit récolter toutes
les informations pour évaluer les
indemnisations
quand vous allez voir les gens chez eux
en situation ils vous disent pas la même
chose
le camp voleurs savaient cheyrou préfet
pragmatique joël de béchu s'adapte à ce
nouveau rythme de vie sans chauffeur
sans apparat sans trop de stress
or j'ai vécu des moments plus exaltant
en termes de rythme de vie si j'ose dire
mais encore une fois quand on est au
service public ont choisi par le
dispositif
on s'y insèrent et on essaye de le faire
aussi bien que possible préfet
hors-cadre préfet hors norme joël le
biscuit ignore quelle sera sa prochaine
affectation comme tous les préfets de
france du sport voici la composition de
la liste des 18 joueurs retenus pour
france pologne de football ce sera
mercredi prochain au stade de france
aucun changement si ce n'est l'arrivée
en doublure de fabien barthez du gardien
de but lionel et easy de metz en
revanche thierry henry n'y figure pas
dans la sélection de roger lemerre avant
de s'offrir au football de stade de
france se consacrera samedi au rugby
avec france angleterre 15 devient dans
la porte et comportera un seul
changement avec le demi d'ouverture
alain penaud mais cette rencontre france
angleterre est à chaque fois un
événement une sorte de finale avant la
lettre où tous les poncifs historiques
comme les bonnes vieilles rancunes
s'exprime parfois d'ailleurs christophe
duchiron avec laurent chemla nous en
font maintenant un habile concentré
malgré une estime réciproque entre
français et anglais il y a toujours eu
comme un fossile d'ordre culturel
ils nous traitent de froggy's ce qui en
anglais pourrait se traduire par
mangeurs de grenouilles pour gentiment
nous moquer nous les appelons les
rosbifs ce qui en anglais veut dire aux
griffes comme en france et d'ailleurs
sans aller jusqu'à évoquer jeanne d'arc
waterloo et la crise de la vache folle
d'un simple point de vue rugbystique les
confrontations franco anglaise dans
l'union générale à des débats toujours
viril et parfois pas très correct car
dès lors qu'il s'agit de suprématie de
chaque côté de la manche on a l'honneur
chatouilleux et le bras vengeur cette
semaine à l'entraînement entre autres
exercices de culture physique les bleus
ont affûté les muscles et travailler le
disco tôt car le match de samedi
s'annonce physique
maintenant pour ce qui est du climat
général l'heure est à la détente et à la
diplomatie
peu ou pas de petites phrases assassines
de part et d'autre restons prudents les
on dirait que les temps changent sont
les joueurs qui ont du coeur qui sont
fougueux je me rends là l'ancien
talonneur moore qui était vraiment un
vrai plus beau sauter mais après que
c'est un gars hyper adorable du doigt
aujourd'hui c'est ça il ya un peu
provocation procédé lui mettre un peu
dans ce match mais après c'est je dirais
plutôt dans l'ordi aprilia plus problème
on boit un verre ensemble et tout
s'efface pour mémoire fut un temps de
sciences d'angleterre était fait de dur
à cuire
si messieurs les anglais aimé jouer
monsieur propre en accusant les français
de toutes les violences
alors qu'il ne se privaient de rien les
sujets de sa gracieuse majesté même du
fir dans le domaine interdit de l'anti
jeu
soyons honnêtes les français n'ont pas
toujours fait dans la dentelle mais
quand ils sont pris ils sont punis par
larbi comme ce match de 1990
où nos joueurs seront expulsés parfois
les anglais nerfs si le médecin avant
d'exercer était le serment d'hippocrate
le joueur anglais quand ils jouent fait
souvent le serment d'hypocrite l'anglais
paradoxal il
il est truffé d'ambiguïté il ya un
discours antinomiques entre le terrain
et en dehors du terrain et moi j'ai
toujours eu du mal à concevoir de
pouvoir me mettre des tartines pendant
le match et puis boire une bière juste
derrière jeu l'an dernier ce week-end à
5h et vaincu anglais et français sortait
du terrain bras dessus bras dessous
les anglais l'avaient largement emporté
au score mais attention les français au
bout venger les grenouilles
il aime aussi le rosbif du cinéma le 1er
mars prochain sur les écrans en france
le film de scott elliott une carte du
monde l'histoire d'une femme dans une
petite ville de l'état du wisconsin aux
états unis dont la vie va basculer il ya
d'abord la mort d'un enfant dont elle
avait la garde
il ya ensuite la rumeur la suspicion
d'une collectivité alors qu'elle est
accusé d'attouchements sexuels une carte
du monde celle de quelqu'un qui rêve
d'une société idéale et paisible mais le
film raconte une sorte d'enchaînement
infernal avec notamment cette
arrestation d'alice interprétée par
sigourney weaver que nous retrouverons
juste après ça nous avons un mandat
d'arrêt contre lui pour abus sexuel
suivez nous s'il vous plaît par ici
l'avancé
poser les mains sur le capot vous avez
le droit de garder le silence owen
avocat
si vous n'avez pas les moyens vous en
aurez un commune de fils à lui à l'us
ward robin mc et si dit que je lui ai
fait des choses affreuses qu'est ce qui
se passe j'ai de sérieux ennuis la liste
ce bout de papier est ce que quelqu'un
peut plus de 6 face au wat
non je ne vais pas te dire ça qu'il faut
que tu fasses pour l'instant ce qu'il
faut c'est que tu t'occupes dit si je te
répondrais été que j'aurais régler tout
ça non mais enfin à corte mois une
minute je viens avec sonore nauphary
soir les filles
et puis il y avait peu pourquoi vous
l'arrêter s'il vous plaît ni chez moi
soyez sages est d'accord l'issue écoutez
bien papa elle est en route
resté dans la voiture fanen avocat non
tu sais bien qu'on en paye on met un peu
en dessous de leurs racines
il s'appelle reverdy serré dalpé il
paraît aussi de meilleurs contacts le
faut que j'appelle quelqu'un s'il ya
quelqu'un que je peux amener au
commissariat pour que j'appelle qui
bonsoir je suis vous parlait bien
français bien vous avez vous exprimer en
anglais je crois vous préférez people
français alors parlons de ce film ce qui
est fascinant dans ce film c'est
l'enchaînement des événements qui vont
faire basculer la vie de cette femme
c'est à dire que au fond c'est quelqu'un
qui avait tout pour vivre une vie
heureuse tranquille et puis il ya la
mort d'un enfant il ya la suspicion la
rumeur et tout ça c'est un enchaînement
comme une machine infernale
on peut dire que c'est une histoire
d'une femme qui comme on dit ce grâce il
y à un événement et puis ça change la
vie pour toujours et toute la famille
doit faire les ajustements pour pour
survivre et cette femme hépatique
éléments très audacieuse en être et ça
se met dans beaucoup d des troubles ce
qui est terrible c'est le l'effet de la
rumeur il ya cette rumeur qui naît de la
plaint d'un enfant et puis tout là toute
la petite ville toute la bourgade va se
mettre à l'accusé à la croix non
seulement coupable d'avoir tué un enfant
meurt c noyer mais aussi d'avoir fait
des attouchements sexuels salon mène en
prison
l'idée de la rumeur c'est quelque chose
qui est très fort dans dans le dans le
petit village
yes et c'est oui c'est un peu qu'ils
attendent quelque chose qui peut vous
prouver comme ils le gagnent d'être net
chinois le verbe ya longtemps déjà
square excentrique les nations trick de
vente pour une petite ville
elle est toujours belle et d un petit
peu un point de vente et dans le film et
demain ils peuvent en fait les gens
veulent jeu là me reprocher aux
différentes est logique
elle faisait elle est très ironique elle
ne fait pas le rôle de lave linge et
dien elle est en fait c'est très
pragmatique à propos de ces petits
événements de la vie et montre comment
les gens et bien sentir cirque elle pas
cependant à des états profondément
dépressif est très dur très violente et
entend totalement désespérée vous êtes
quelque fois reconnu où vous sentez très
distantes ce genre d'attitude de femmes
enfin je pense que chacun d'entre nous
ont fait des eaux visite
alice se sont très coupables de cette
tragique de cette tragédie est comme ça
personne est plus dur ce n que mm quand
elle va en prison c'est un peu un
commencement pour elle parce qu'elle est
puni que ça ne punit pas elle-même mais
je pense que l aile
elles se cachent beaucoup d émotion pour
pour survivre c'est un film où les
femmes sont très fortes
là vous vous interprétez alice il ya
teresa qui est très forte
la mère de l'enfant qui est bon il ya
des femmes prisonnières avec lequel vous
allez vivre dans ce centre pénitentiaire
et les hommes en revanche sont pas très
courageux un peu distant oui c'est
différent comme les films de hollywood
parce que vraiment le focus c'est le
l'amitié de ces deux mères les enfants
jouent ensemble ils sont très très près
et quand cet accident se passe on peut
voir vraiment
les méthodes du monde et rejette aussi
les jargons voir une telle amitié à
l'écran et oisif orange si réelle et
crédible pour moi aux états unis c'est
une chose que j'aime le plus à propos de
ce fier et précisément sait qui il est
il est vrai et authentique les gens font
des erreurs et on peut vraiment
s'identifier à ces 7 0 et cette héroïne
en particulier mais c'est ce que vous
pensez des femmes vous pensez que les
femmes sont plus courageuses que les
hommes ap ap le met traditionnellement
c'est les femmes qui sont sous sur les
dons les fermes et les les endroits
comme ça qu'on laisse les hommes vont
quand combattre les guerres et fonde les
femmes se retrouvent seuls ils défendent
leur famille et je pense que les femmes
ont eu à être forte et peut-être qu'on
ne vous le fais pas toujours savoir à
vous les hommes et mais quand il s'agit
de protéger vos propres enfants votre
famille votre foyer je pense que les
femmes ont lu à devenir forte et
indépendante elle prouvé dans le film
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
cette séquence qui se passe dans un
centre pénitentiaire on parle beaucoup
actuellement aux etats-unis de la peine
de mort le gouverneur de l'illinois
décidé d'un moratoire sur la peine de
mort quel est votre votre position c'est
que la majorité des américains sont pour
la peine de mort qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce débat je ne suis pas en
faveur de la peine de mort est l'une des
choses qui s'est produit
du fait de la découverte des tests de
l'adn il ya beaucoup de gens dont on a
prouvé qu'ils étaient innocents ou au
dernier moment parce que on avait de
nouvelles preuves et je pense que le
gouvernement a eu tout à fait raison de
déclarer ce moratoire je pense qu'on
fait de toute façon la peine de mort est
absurde mais malheureusement il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont enfin si vous
êtes un personnage multiple comme ça
vous êtes capable de passer d'alien
alice c'est très différent tout ça est
ce que c'est un peu vous même est ce que
vous même vous êtes très multiples un
peu style j'aime beaucoup me mettre dans
la peau des autres crir la comédienne
être dans le drame j'ai vu je me suis
chanceuse d'être alice parce que elle
est très amusante et pour une audience
américaine elle est une héroïne
ceci a été certainement un défi le défi
majeur de ma carrière et après j'ai dû
faire trois comédies pour m'en remettre
merci beaucoup nous avons rendu visite
on était très honoré vous soyez là je
voudrais dire qu'il ya le livre aux
éditions l'archipel la carte du monde de
john hamilton qui a donné ce ce film
dakar du monde qu'on verra partir du 1er
mars
je le montre la voie là jean pierre
merci beaucoup merci voilà nous arrivons
à la fin d'édition je voudrais vous
rappeler l'information sur la vache
malade qui ne l'était pas repéré par les
services vétérinaires dans un abattoir
du morbihan n'avait pas la maladie de la
vache folle les analyses pratiquées le
confirme l p dg de la batteur galets du
sourn dans le morbihan estime que cette
affaire lui a causé un préjudice
considérable et d'aller finisseur
demande réparation pour l'éleveur dans
quelques secondes la météo avec isabelle
martinet le point route avec valérie
maurice est très important car le
week-end s'annonce très difficile sur
les routes dans le magazine envoyé
spécial qui suivra présenté par paul
nahon il sera question de langue
française du rap et de l'alaska à une
heure vous retrouverez pour journal de
la nuit thierry culié demain 7h50 gérard
morin recevra serge dassault à 13h vous
trouvez
mais mme carole gaessler et rachid arhab
et à 20h bien sûr béatrice schönberg à
lundi bonsoir merci beaucoup
tous